ha ha happy times no no no hey guys i'm
abby Sharpe welcome to Abby's kitchen
Santa's coming and if you're like me and
getting ready to host you know things
are about to become a bit of a [ __ ] show
I mean after the insanity that is
opening gifts with sugar fueled kids you
somehow got a muster up the energy to
run a marathon in your kitchen in order
to get a six-course dinner on the table
for a reasonable hour think you've got
time for a leisurely midday meal it's a
nice holiday thought honey but forget
about it so that's why the holiday
breakfast is so heat to give you that
energy to get you through the day plus
help prevent you from binging on orders
for your guests even arrived so I've got
this fun DIY a wheel bar for you and
your family that has the perfect
combination of fiber and protein that's
totally gonna fuel your day let's get to
it first in a small pot combine the oats
with the water salt and cinnamon bring
the mixture to a simmer over medium high
heat then reduce the heat to medium stir
the pot occasionally until the oats is
absorbed almost all of the water
but are still very moist and thick in a
bowl beat the egg whites until they
froth up then add them to the pot with
the oats cook stirring constantly until
the mixture is creamy and fluffed up
then stir in the vanilla the banana then
turn off the heat cover the pot and let
the oat sit for another 3 minutes until
they really puff up and get super creamy
and rich now it's time to decorate I
think having a fun little oatmeal bar is
a really great little experience for you
and your family because everyone gets to
mix-and-match all their favorite flavors
so these are some of my go-to
combinations first go tropical with some
mango Kiwi coconut cashews and a little
coconut milk next one op TB and
chocolate add some bananas a swirl of
peanut butter a little cocoa powder some
peanuts and some cacao nibs finally try
middle-eastern Flair with some sliced
fix pistachios Greek yogurt pomegranate
seeds and a drizzle
thanks so much for watching guys be sure
to give me the best thumbs up if you
like this video subscribe to the channel
and leave me a comment below I want to
know what some of your tips tricks and
hacks are making the holidays way easier
and a little healthier too thanks again
for watching and I'll see you next time
on Abby's kitchen
[Music]